[Music]
all right good morning everybody my name
is Sandeep Parikh I run our retail
solutions architecture practice for a
Google cloud and this morning I want to
talk to you about end-to-end
collaborative data workflows and what
those look like inside a Google cloud
platform so what we're gonna cover today
first I want to lay out a pretty simple
straightforward challenge for you and
then we'll break it down into the
individual tasks that we're gonna have
this team sort of work on and try to
work through and then we'll map those
tasks to a set of steps components and
tools that you would want to leverage
inside of GCP it's actually accomplished
the initial challenge and then we'll try
to put it all together and give you a
sense of what that again that end-to-end
workflow looks like and I'm hoping I'm
gonna be able to show you a little bit
of a demo as well now unfortunately it's
not gonna be a live demo it turns out it
takes about six to eight hours for the
antenna workflow and I didn't want to
keep you here for the whole day so we're
just gonna have to do it food network
style and I'll have everything kind of
pre baked already but we'll walk through
what the steps and the UI looks like in
every stage and then finally I want to
close on what's next and I'm gonna try
to leave a few minutes for questions at
the end and worst-case scenario just
come find me right outside the hall and
I'm happy to chat it up with you we've
also got mics in the aisles here as well
all right so with that what problem are
we trying to solve what does a data team
typically have to try to solve on a
regular basis so we'll pick everybody's
favorite and say our challenge here is
to build a recommendation system now
that recommendation system is something
we hope to use inside of running web
application so you could imagine sort of
a Netflix tile challenge here where
we've got a web app we've got folks who
are able to rate movies and what we want
them to do is be able to see
recommendations in line as they're
browsing so what is a team made up of
wait what is the typical audience where
the the folks that are trying to put
this thing together so we've got sort of
the typical cast of characters data
scientists a data engineer a business
analyst and an app developer right and I
think depending
your organization those roles may be
different they may be there may be some
overlap among them but ultimately these
are kind of the four main team pillars
we typically see in a lot of customers
all right so what are the sort of steps
are that the tasks that these teams have
to work through so the first thing is
often fall to the data engineer and
that's where they've got to transform
the data they're given right you could
imagine a DBA or someone that's kind of
running sre for a database
infrastructure they may just export some
of the source data that they're going to
use to build this recommendation system
so the first step is taking that export
taking that raw data and turning into
something useful the next step falls to
the business analyst where they actually
have to develop some kind of an
understanding of the data right this may
be things like you know just early
analytical queries something that gives
them a sense of what does this data
really look like right we're not going
to have the data engineer figure that
out it's really on them to transform
then it falls into the business analyst
to understand what's in that inside that
data set well then we're going to get to
model building so the first step for the
data scientist now is to prototype an
approach and you can imagine at every
step of the process you know these folks
are learning from the previous steps so
that data scientist may collaborate with
that business analyst and get some early
indication of some of the patterns that
are inside that data set and they may
use that as their prototyping their
approach to building this model but
first they've got to get that
prototyping done so they've got to come
up with some kind of an approach they're
gonna use to build this machine learning
model and then they actually have to
physically build it right they've got to
build it train it and even on a small
data set or local environment but
they've got to do something to actually
create this model but then once that
model is trained and ready to go how do
they get it out into production and
that's where the data engineer comes
back into play right because it's not
only important just to build the model
know that it works we've also got to run
this thing at scale so it can support
the application downstream so that data
engineer is going to deploy that model
to production and then the last step is
going to be integrating that that
prediction mechanism
with the applications all right so let's
start with the first set of tasks how do
we transform and understand data inside
of GCP right so remember that's that
first chunk of that timeline with the
data engineer and the business analyst
so there's three main steps that
typically fall into this bucket and and
you know I'm sure this is not completely
exhaustive right there's typically a lot
more work that might go on here but
these are three of the biggest pillars
that we often run into so the first step
is really gonna be acquiring that data
right grabbing all that raw data raw
data and storing it in some kind of
object storage mechanism something
that's nice and scalable we can access
from a number of different tools then
we'll have to turn all those flat files
into something useful right put some
structure on that data cleanser
transform it turn into something where
we can actually run queries against it
and start learning from the data set and
after that transformation is done we
actually want to put it somewhere where
we can access it right so typically
inside of a large-scale data warehouse
so this is day three of next so you
probably can guess which tools I'm going
to show you here but so for acquiring
and storing the data object storage GCS
Google Cloud Storage is a great fit for
that for transforming the flat files and
the structured data we actually have a
bunch of different tools we can use here
but I like using data prep mostly
because it's a nice visual way to sort
of dig around and understand sample data
and we'll talk through a little bit of
that as we get further in and then the
last piece is bigquery right petabyte
scale analytical data warehouse a
perfect place for ad-hoc queries again
we're in kind of understanding and model
building phase so it's early on this
doesn't have to serve any kind of
transactional traffic or anything all
we're focused on doing is giving
ourselves access to query and understand
the data so if we dig into each one of
those just a little bit this is an
example of what what GCS looks like
right it's just an ice bucket folder
style approach where I've created a
bucket in this case and the dataset I'm
using as we're working through this
example is like the movie lens dataset
so I grabbed the 20 million rating movie
lens dataset unzipped it dropped all the
CSVs
in to Google Cloud storage so now I've
got the raw data sitting here
so the next step is transformation
that's where data prep comes in now as I
mentioned data prep it is a great data
wrangling tool right it lets you pull in
from cloud storage or bigquery transform
all the data you want to transform
against and then actually dump that data
back out into cloud storage or into
bigquery so it gives you that that input
and output option what's really cool
about data prep is that behind the
scenes the the transformations that you
define the steps that you take the
filters you run are actually packaged up
into an Apache beam job and that beam
job is actually pushed to the data flow
service so the actual execution
mechanism here is actually cloud
dataflow behind the scenes and now the
inputs and outputs here with data prep
are somewhat limited right this doesn't
cover the breadth of the platform if you
need a level deeper of maybe
transformations or maybe you want to get
through maybe inputting from cloud
datastore and outputting to a cloud
sequel or clouds banner that's where you
want to incorporate data flow but for
our use case data prep works perfectly
well because our data's living in cloud
storage and we want to make sure it
lands in bigquery eventually so this is
an example of the data prep UI and what
you'll see and again I'll go through
this a little bit more in depth as we
get to the demo part but what I want you
to notice is that we've got this kind of
row and column setup right this is a CSV
that I imported and this is the cleanse
kind of ready to go output but what
you'll see across the top there and
those green bars are actually data prep
sampling the entire column and showing
me a distribution of all possible values
there and so that kind of tooling makes
the analysis process much easier right
it helps me figure out which of these
data sets do I want to worry about which
of these columns do I care about which
ones do I want to potentially transform
or join as I'm thinking about what I'm
gonna give access to my business analyst
and so here's what a flow looks like so
in the example I'm going to show you I
have the movie lunch 20 million rating
data set so I've got the movies data set
up at the upper left the next one is
ratings the links file includes like the
movie database link or ID and the IMDB
ID for the movie
and then the last one in the very bottom
there is the tax and I didn't really
worry too much about tags but what
you'll see up here is that I've taken
the movie lens over the movies portion
of the data set and the first thing I
did was clean it up a little bit and so
things like genres where pipe separated
text fields and I want to make that a
JSON array so I was able to do that
inside there as well as do things like
extract the year out of the title and
make that its own column then I was
actually able to join it with other
datasets inside of this whole large
group so I took the ratings and I
actually created an average rating right
so kind of a little bit of a swoop down
to the bottom there but I was able to
compute the average ratings per movie
from that 20 million set and then push
those average ratings and join them up
back with the movies and so the nice
thing here is that the movies data set
itself was actually able to be enriched
all done inside of this tool and so all
of those little and they're a little bit
hard to see but all those little arrows
that are pointing to the right at the
end of every step those are actually the
job that's the output component so
that's where I get to decide where do I
want to put this data out to do I want
to append it to an existing table inside
of bigquery or replace the data set so
you have a lot of flexibility with data
prep it gives you a lot of
transformational power around around
individual data sets and how you might
want to work with them join them use
them so once that set of jobs runs all
my data lands inside of bigquery and
here's just a quick screenshot of what
that looks like inside of bigquery so
I've got my sort of options on the upper
left and I've got my data sets on the
lower left there and then we see a
little bit of information about the
actual physical data set itself
screenshots not very exciting I'll show
you more when we actually run some
queries but here's a quick show a screen
shot of what that looks like
inside the the bigquery UI so you can
see we can run standard sequel queries
against this data now so any sequel
capabilities you might have for your
business analysts they're able to go
ahead and run ad-hoc queries immediately
against this data set so we're already
making a little bit of progress through
the work that we've got to do to get to
get to build that recommendation system
so if we want to get a level deeper on
exploring
understanding data I think sequel is a
really powerful tool but it's not the
right tool for every single person out
there and there are an incredibly huge
number of business intelligence tools
out there that we want to be able to
plug into so the great thing about
bigquery is that it does support things
like tableau and looker and our own data
studio products so that you can build
things like reports dashboards build
kind of exploratory analyses of the data
that you're looking at so it's another
nice way to think about how can I
examine and understand this data because
that's really what we're trying to get
to we're trying to make sure we can
develop a really intense in-depth
understanding if we're trying to build a
predictive component on top of it all
right so we've finished the first major
set of tasks right we acquired the data
set and we've transformed it into
something useful we've got a bunch of
tools we can use to really develop an
understanding but how do we make the
next leap how do we move into building a
machine learning model so that's what
the data scientist comes in right if you
remember we have two big tasks here one
we've got a prototype the approach and
the second is we actually if that build
the model itself so the components that
you'll need to accomplish those tasks
right for a data scientist one obviously
you're gonna need a pretty powerful
machine learning framework that's
something that you can lean on heavily
to support this kind of work and then
you actually need an environment to
physically you know prototype the
approach within so what's that a GCP we
have two good options there for you
tensorflow which is a scalable machine
learning library and framework and cloud
data lab which you can just imagine as
jupiter notebooks or python ipython
notebooks as a service so let's dig in a
little bit tensorflow is incredibly
powerful it's also relatively
complicated and I'm a tensorflow newbie
myself so this took me a little bit of
work to get all this up and running but
think of it as a powerful open source
library for really high-performance
numerical computation the great thing
about tensorflow is I think it
establishes a really nice kind of
baseline and what you're seeing within
the ecosystem now is a lot of stuff
that's sitting on top of tensorflow
higher level abstractions that are
making easier and easier to work with
and tensorflow itself is and improving
at an incredible pace it actually is
able to run on a number of different
environments though as well right it can
run on just bare CPUs GPUs or even our
own tensor floor tensor processing units
or TP use that are available inside a GC
P and it can be deployed those models
can be deployed to run on anything from
mobile devices to large-scale you know
VM infrastructure so it really is a very
capable framework and there is a
incredible number of blog posts how-to
guides tutorials out there right all the
way from formal to informal of how to
use tensor flow for different classes of
problem so we've got a good framework we
can build on well now we need an
environment to prototype it in and
that's where again Cloud Data lab comes
in and think of data lab as just a wide
open notebook interface but we've
actually tweaked the Jupiter and the
ipython components a little bit to give
you access to some really simple tools
so for example inside that that notebook
we give you a quick access to running
things like a bigquery queries or
looking at files out of Google Cloud
storage without having to import
individual libraries and set those up so
we try to make it as easy as possible
and a first-class citizen amongst all
the other data data services that you
might want to leverage but inside those
notebooks you can explore that data you
can obviously analyze it visualization
components are built right in and it's
actually perfectly suited to building
machine learning models and it actually
plugs directly into using tensorflow and
even deploying those models later on so
here's an example of what the dataflow
herbs are the cloud data lab UI looks
like again very notebook driven but you
can see we've got a mix of I'm running
some queries I'm charting some of the
output I'm importing some Python
libraries I'm actually writing a
function here for training all right so
now we've got the first four bits done
right we acquired the data which
transformed into something useful
we were able to prototype our approach
right with a machine learning framework
in an environment and we're able to
start building our model now that that's
all done how do we and maybe we even
trained it in that case in a small kind
of constrained environment but now how
do we train it and deploy it and run it
at scale and really incorporate the
usage of that model right so we've got
the next step here is deploying that
model and training and deploying it and
running it at scale so for the data
engineer there's two main steps they've
got to take first thing is they've got
to push that model to the cloud to train
it and then deploy it ultimately on a
running service that can scale and then
they've got to integrate that prediction
mechanism into an application so the
steps that we have there are or the
tools that we want to use there are
cloud machine learning engine and our
cloud API is which are basically just
the kind of endpoint you're going to use
here cloud machine learning engine is an
incredibly compelling product because it
takes your tensorflow model or it takes
your training tasks and it lets you run
it on a much larger set of
infrastructure so you can run things
like your tensorflow models at an
incredible scale without having to worry
about spinning up those machines
configuring them installing all the rest
cart software coordinating the work that
they do
alright tensorflow is built to be
distributed so we can take advantage of
that and create a large cluster and
deploy the job - so they can complete
the training process and then when that
training process is done you could
actually take that completed model and
push it back up to the service and say
now I want to make this a serving model
and it gives you back a URL endpoint
that you can integrate inside of your
applications so the example of what that
flow looks like for pushing the cloud
and training and deploying would be you
might want to do some light
pre-processing or heavy depending on
your input data but you're going to
pre-process the data set you've got and
then you're going to submit a training
job and that training job is a Python
tensorflow training task you're gonna
push that job up and there are a series
of parameters that will will talk
through quickly later on but effectively
you're just giving this job to the
service and saying here's my training
task I want
run it across a number of machines once
that job is done it'll actually have a
little output model and here I take that
model and say now create an entry for
that for that serving model inside of
CML II inside of cloud ml engine and
then you can create a version so you
actually have the ability here now to
take different models you've created
attached versions to them and maybe even
a B test them as far as like predictions
go so you have that capability here once
you run that last command it's actually
going to create that that URL endpoint
and give you an option to again
integrate that into an application so
there's two ways you can actually test
the prediction mechanism coming through
the top we actually have a test
capability built into the g-cloud
command inside of the G cloud SDK so you
can just run g-cloud a Melungeon predict
tell it the model you want to print it
against
give it some input data and out pops
your answer or you can come in from the
bottom and integrate into application
and it really is just a URL you get to
post against right this is a service
that we host for you and scale for you
as needed so that's just an API you
integrate and you can post against or
you actually have the option of going a
step further here and saying I'm gonna
wrap this inside of a more powerful like
Cloud endpoints approach so I have a
good set of API management capabilities
on top of it it's up to you but
ultimately it's still the same back-end
infrastructure where both those commands
land you inside of Cloud ml engine and
you get those predictions back out all
right so let's put it all together and
figure out what this looks like so you
remember we've got these six main kind
of components right transforming
understanding prototyping the approach
building the model deploying it at scale
and integrating with applications so
when you map that back to GCP right you
get the sort of appropriate kind of
components here right so for
transforming we use data prep for
understanding we would use bigquery for
prototyping and maybe building the model
we might use cloud data lab when we
deploy it we're gonna deploy it to cloud
ml engine and finally we'll use the API
that comes out or we can again use Cloud
endpoints to actually integrate with our
running application
all right so it's part of this I did
want to walk you through as much of the
UI and in real world as much as possible
so I'm gonna show don't tell and here's
where the demo should be so if we could
switch to the Chromebook all right great
can you guys read this yes okay try and
make it a little bit bigger all right so
it's not too much exciting to show here
other than this is the cloud storage
bucket where I actually dumped the movie
lens 20 million rating data set into so
you can see these are just a raw CSV
files I'm not terribly exciting at this
part of it quite yet but now we can
actually start a data prep flow so what
I did instead of data prep is I started
a new flow and I imported those data
sets I said here's where my data lives
inside of Google Cloud storage and now I
actually want to take some action on it
so the first one was the movies data set
if you remember and we executed this
cleanup phase so I'm gonna switch to my
cleanup tab make sure you so inside of
data prep as I mentioned earlier you can
see across the top that it's actually
sampling all of these columns and
showing me the distribution of data in
them which is actually pretty handy
again as you're trying to figure out
what is in these data sets and so what
you're seeing right now on screen is
actually the completed version right
this is a cleanse version well what if I
want to see the initial version right
before I actually ran all these steps
that are here on the right so I can
click on a step and I'll show now it's
actually showing me the the kind of
output before that step I'm sorry the
the version right after it executed that
step so you'll see I've got things like
the movie ID the title with the year
still in the title and there's on race
as a pipe separated column but that pipe
separation is not really helpful so I'm
actually able to here just you know
define a set of steps like extract
occurrences of the word from each of
those pipe separated genres and then
drop that into a column here on the
right called extract list drama genres
and you can see it's now it's an array
and then I actually am able to delete
the field and rename it to
genres right to match up what we need
and then the last step is I want to
extract the year from that title and
actually make it a separate column on
its own alright so we can see the steps
here and I'm just using regular
expressions to pull the year out drop
the parentheses and move that into its
own column I show you this step in a
little bit more depth so the first thing
I do is I pick a column and then I have
the option to pick either some pre can't
you know canned values here for for
searching inside of that column or I can
pick a custom pattern so I picked a
custom pattern and they said you know
four digits made sure I gave it some
parameters about when to start and end
that that regular expression and that's
it and it's often running I was able to
add that to the flow and I changed the
title that extracted column into an
actual year and then I did a little bit
of cleanup on the actual individual
column movie titles himself so things
like removing quotes removing any extra
spaces that were a trailing or at the
end and that's the cleanup step so if
you go back to the flow here so the
first thing I did was I took that raw
CSV I imported it I cleaned up the file
a bit to make a little bit easier to
query and use later on but I'm not done
yet I want to add a couple of fields in
so I wanted to add things like the links
the movie ID started the movie database
ID itself as well as the IMDB ID and I
also wanted to have inside that movies
data set the average rating and the
number of ratings so on the ratings data
set I actually added this average
ratings by movie and you can actually
see the the functions that it ran
I just basically computed a collapsed
that rating data set and the way it's
actually originally organized it's user
ID movie ID rating and a timestamp so
all I did was I grouped by user and
movie and I collapsed it down into
compute the averages themselves and then
I was able to join that with back with
the movies data set itself so here's
what that joint looks like and it's a
pretty simple approach first thing I did
was I executed a lookup if you could see
that up there against another data set
in this case links so I was able to pull
in the links file and then I did another
joint where I look up the movie ID
against the movie ID in the ratings data
set that I can
peuta and actually pulled in the average
ratings that I wanted to so now my
dataset looks like movie ID average
rating number of ratings I did total
rating as well and then the links as
well as the titles the year and the
genres that we talked about earlier so
I've got a pretty far away far way
through transforming that data set so
now the last bit we have to do is as I
mentioned is this little arrow up here
and this actually is the job right this
is where tell it's I'm telling the flow
where do I want to deposit that the
result of that transformation and so in
this case I'm actually gonna do I'm
gonna pull in from that CSV and I'm
gonna replace whatever's in the movie
lens dataset inside a big query so when
I run that job what happens and I'm not
gonna run it now unfortunately cuz I
will take about 30 minutes but what's
actually happening behind the scenes is
it's taking those transformations all
that all that work you saw those are the
components in that recipe all those
tasks and it's packaging them up as an
Apache beam job and then pushing that
beam job to the data flow servers and so
the data flow service gets that job and
says okay well I might need to run four
or five six who knows how many workers
I'm gonna spin up those workers they'll
pull in the input data set and actually
execute those transformations all right
so this is something I don't have to get
involved in I just run that job and I
get to walk away and then if I want to
see the results there later on I could
see that I ran some of these each of
those was a job out coming so this movie
lens component right I ran from but
looks like it took about 12 minutes to
run it through the ratings data set took
a little bit longer because it's a much
larger file there but we've got the data
and big crane out so now it's in
bigquery why don't we go ahead and take
a look at it and do some queries and see
what it looks like that might be a
little bit too big so I'm gonna just
close this on the left inside the
bigquery UI inside of the cloud console
you can see things like query history
any saved queries job history if you
want to start some transfers from
another service you can do those we're
gonna right now focus on just querying
this data set that I've got so the movie
--lens data set and I'm looking at the
movies table itself I'm just gonna close
that and so we can see here inside the
UI I'm able to take a look at things
like
the actual fields that are in the in
this table some details around maybe the
size right it's not incredibly large
about 2.6 megabytes and we can also do a
quick preview so we actually can go
through this and again start exploring
the data and looking at a little bit
more depth here but looking at it just
by itself is not very exciting so why
don't we write a query so maybe I wanted
to find out let's say what the top rated
movies are for the action genre so what
I would do is select say movie ID
average rating and title in their genres
so I'm gonna I want those columns to
show up and I'm gonna do from movie lens
movies and I would need to filter it out
by a specific genre that I'm looking for
so I'm actually gonna be able to examine
inside each of those rows the array
field that holds all those genres and
actually pull out the one I want so I'm
going to search for the comedy genre so
I'm gonna use the string position
function say where instead of the genres
field I'm looking for outside action
movies and actions greater than zero
that means it found the column there or
found that entry inside of the genre and
let's say the top 10 well actually let's
first sort it so we can say order by
number of ratings and in descending
order and by average rating in
descending order
and we're gonna get the top ten oops a
little type of never type live on stage
as you will always miss type all right
so that's our query and one quick thing
which I love about the bigquery UI is
it's hard to read through this later on
so you actually have this nice option of
formatting your query automatically so
it makes it a lot easier to read later
on definitely take advantage of that if
you can but now we can run this and it's
actually going to run in a couple of
seconds here alright so now we've got a
list of the top ten action movies and
you can see the genres in there on the
right side we've got the the list of
movies here none of these are probably
surprising to anyone of you but again
this is a sample data set but you get
the sense here we can actually start
querying and playing with this data and
we can even do things like right from
this UI click explore and data studio
and it actually throw us in there and
start giving us some canned charts we
can work against but now we've gone
through the first steps right we've
started Trent we transform the data we
developed a kind of a quick
understanding around it using sequel or
you can use other tools like data studio
look at our tableau or pick your
favorite bi tool but now we want to move
on to the next step we want to say well
let's actually do a some analysis from
the data scientists perspective so
here's my cloud data lab Python notebook
and as I mentioned earlier inside of
those notebooks you actually have this
great capability to run a whole series
of kind of canned commands around things
like running queries right in line
without actually having to do the work
of importing the bigquery SDK and
connecting to a data set and running a
query that way we actually give you a
lot of those capabilities just go to
out-of-the-box to make it easier over
time so here I can actually show you
let's just do a quick little sequel test
of I can run a query using the the %
sequel directive and I'm gonna just
select the top movies the top 10 movies
that I find back from the movie lens
dataset I can execute that query and
you'll see that yes you'll note that
that was cash cuz I ran all this stuff
about 30 minutes before you guys got
here to make sure it still worked so now
we can see all these all the outputs
here and actually one of the others than
we do we give you a couple different
ways to query so one
that sequel directive another one is the
BQ directive and the Beek BQ one is
actually a lot more powerful it gives
you different capabilities inside of the
command so if I were to write something
like let's see let me just add a quick
little code bit here I can say % BQ nope
all right now you can see there's a
whole bunch of stuff you can do here
right you can take operations on
datasets tables create or execute
queries right do things like sampling
you can even create user-defined
functions JavaScript and run those so
you have a lot of work you can actually
create inside of a lot of work you can
do inside of this notebook all by itself
but what we're gonna do here is we're
just gonna say let's get a let's do a
quick aggregation a quick group buy of
all the movies in our data set by their
average rating right just to see what
that distribution looks like so the
first thing I do is I'm actually gonna
write this query out so select average
rating is rating count star is count
from movies and group by average rating
and now I can actually run that and it
actually didn't run the query all it did
was it saved it into that variable named
average ratings count and now I can
actually refer to that refer back to
that later on and say just execute that
name that previously named query so I'll
run through that here and show you so
that's gonna actually run that average
ratings count query I created and it
shows you the distribution which is good
right now we can get a quick view of it
but what if that's not the best way to
look at this data set right if it's
easier to create a chart there's
actually turns out there's a chart
directive as well and I'll show you a
quick bit of that help so I can say
chart and inside there you can see we
actually support a number of charts
depending on the kind of data you want
to look at whether you want it to be a
candlestick chart or maybe a time line
or a tree map or a histogram all those
capabilities are kind of baked right
into the console here or inside of this
notebook so I'm gonna pick columns
because it's an easy way to visualize
that data set so all I have to do here
again is refer back to that query name
that I used earlier that I executed
against and just tell it which fields I
want to pull out from the resulting data
set and see that column
or in a column view and now we can
actually see the distribution so this
might help us as we're trying to figure
out how we want to build our training
task it doesn't really tie into the
recommendation approach but when wanted
to showcase a little bit of the power of
data lab because it does have a lot of
capability baked into this one kind of
straightforward UI and then of course
you know it is ipython or Jupiter
notebook so we have the typical Python
capabilities here tensorflow is actually
already included as are things like
numpy SK learn so I can say import numpy
import scikit-learn or I can say import
pandas so we do as much as we can whoops
that's my fault
we'll come back that one we do as much
as we can to make sure that there's a
lot of the typical libraries you want to
use baked into the data lab kind of core
image that's running here but you also
have the ability to import your own
alright to add your own let's say I
wanted to add something else right
something that wasn't in that wasn't in
the image by default so there we
captured run pip commands inline and
said I could pick pip install somebody
yell at a library should install here
I missed its ad yet I couldn't I
couldn't hear you sorry so I'll just
I'll just pick something now I'm gonna
just pick the six library here cuz
that's pretty straightforward actually
might already be in there so alright I
picked something that was already there
but you can see running pip commands is
also available to you so if you need to
install additional libraries that are
not part of that core that core image
you can do that as well and then the
last bit is actually writing some Python
so I'm not gonna run this here because
there's a whole bunch more functions
than I did I left out but the goal here
is right you could actually create your
training task function right in line
here and actually use some of those
similar directives to run g-cloud
commands it's actually push the training
task function up to the ml engine
service to actually run it and so I
previously did some of that work
and let me take a quick look and show
you what that looks like so here's an
example of what it looked like for me to
submit the training job that I had
earlier right so up at the top I've just
defined a handful of environment
variables right where the input data is
where I wanted to dump some of the
output in this case this data was pre
processed and I'm using actually a
sample that I'll tell you about in a
minute but this sample actually takes
the 20 million rating a movie lens
dataset and it trains a couple of
different models right it does one for a
deep learning model and another for a
matrix factorization model and the when
you look down here at this command what
you're actually seeing is there's two
different sets of arguments the first
set right the first set of arguments are
the actual ones I need to pass to the ml
engine service so things like what is
the actual Python module name of the
task right in this case it's trainer not
tasks where is the path to that to that
package it's right in line in this same
directory I'm in where do I want to
stage the kind of intermediate output
which region you haven't run it in and
what are the some of the configuration
parameters that I want to have there
right so we can specify all those and
then the second set of arguments are
actually arguments to my trainer file
itself to my Python tasks so here I'm
giving it things like where should I be
putting some of the the output data how
you know what about the evaluation type
or maybe some of the other features that
I'm trying to expose here and then I'm
also doing the exact same thing for the
factorization model further down the way
and this is submitting in an async
fashion so you have that option with ml
engine you can either submit in
synchronous or asynchronous
if you do it with sync it streams the
logs from your training output right
back to your console or if your nud
async it gives you back a job ID and
says go ahead and check this job ID
later on to see how it progressed now if
we take a look at the configuration just
to show you really quickly first thing I
do is show you
so this is a one of the input
configuration files we use and this
configuration bid is actually these are
arguments you could specify on the
command line if you wanted to or not but
what they're basically telling ml engine
is how do you want me to run your job
right so in this case the scale tier I
picked and there are different ones but
effectively here you have the option of
saying I need something at the most
basic level so maybe a set of CPUs maybe
I want to run on the quote unquote
premium level which is I think one
master and about 10 workers with GPUs or
I can run with TP use as well so you
have a lot of flexibility to define how
much you want done here how many
components you want to incorporate into
your your training set and actually one
thing I didn't mention that I will
mention here is at the bottom there you
see a section called parameters or
params and ml engine offers this really
cool notion of hyper tuned hyper tuning
your parameters and what that means is
you get to tell us some bounds on
certain parameters in this case I'm
going to talk about learning rate
there's a minute a max and what I want
ml engine to do is run multiple
permutations of this and tell me what's
the right value for a learning rate so
when it finishes this training one of
the outputs here is not just the model
but it's actually going to tell me the
optimum value I should use for a
learning rate so there's a lot of power
just baked into this mechanism where you
give it a task you tell it which
parameters are flexible and that you
want to get the most optimal outcome for
those parameters so we could have
submitted that training job and when we
submit it it goes into that's a little
too big it goes into the ml engine UI
here and I was doing a bunch of training
and breaking things all over the place
so here's one example of the matrix
factorization job I ran it took about
two hours because I was only running it
on a single master with a couple of
workers then you could see all the
inputs that it gave you and the training
output based on the hyper parameters you
gave it so now it's showing me for every
single run
every single trial what the learning
rate it used there and what the kind of
optimal outcome might have been and if
you actually were to look at this inline
when it's running you would actually see
a breakdown of every worker and the CPU
use
across all them the RAM usage so you get
a sense of what's actually physically
happening behind the scenes when we're
running those jobs themselves but once
that training is completed right we
actually have to deploy the model to
production so that's where I'll show you
the final step here that's actually in
the in the previous father we're showing
you but it's the component where I could
actually just run again a series of
g-cloud command actually deploy that
model to a production kind of scaling
service and when you actually run those
a couple of those commands you get a
models in the model section here of the
UI so in my matrix factorization model
that created a default version which is
v1 and I now have the ability to use
that model or set it as default or pick
different versions here again it if
you're thinking about maybe you have
multiple models you want to serve for a
given use case maybe for purposes of a/b
testing different recommendation
approaches the version capability is
really nice to have there because you
can pick and choose what you want to
deploy into but now that's all done
right we've trained our model we've got
it ready to serve we've pushed it up to
production so the last step in this
process is actually getting a prediction
out so what I'm gonna do here is show
you what that prediction looks like
really quickly on the command line so
when you need to you're g-cloud ml
engine I'm gonna predict I'm gonna pick
the model I want so in this case I'm
going to choose the matrix factorization
model and then for my input you have the
option of supplying either a set of
inputs inside of JSON and doing a
synchronous prediction or you can
actually do a bunch of batch predictions
in this case I'm going to do a quick
synchronous one and because this data
was pre processed and using tensorflow
records I'm gonna use a canned TF record
that I had saved off to the side
oops
oops thanks again typos stage always
happens all right so that's gonna start
off and running and this needs to be
warmed up again cuz I'd only ran it an
hour ago and I have it set to turn off
these things this production model if
I'm not using it very often to save a
little bit of money but what it's doing
right now is actually taking that
tensorflow record input and actually
producing it's running it against the
prediction API there that I've decided
upon and giving me an actual physical
output and of course nothing works when
you run it on stage there goes ok so I'm
not gonna tell you what all this means
but basically because of the way I
structured the input data into tensor
flow records I'm using this this this
approach it gives me a set of scores and
output classes for a given user for a
number of different movies so that's a
little bit of that n10 workbook can we
switch back to the slides so I want to
plug a couple things really quickly here
because I didn't do all this work on my
own there's just not enough time to come
up with this entire workflow end to end
so I definitely leaned heavily on some
of the cloud ml samples from the cloud
ml team so they were nice enough to have
a bunch of samples specifically around
this data set that I chose chose which
was really handy but I urge you to check
out that repo because nothing beats
actual end-to-end kind of workflow and
you can read the docs only so often
before you actually need physical steps
to try out so these folks have put
together something really useful that
would definitely take a look at and then
the other thing I leaned on was paper
that one of my colleagues wrote building
recommendation systems and tensorflow
and he actually goes through a similar
approach where he uses movie lens data
set but he also goes all the way to the
end where he talks about things like how
to actually serve the model using Cloud
endpoints so you have a little bit more
API management on top of it where you
get more logging authorization and
monitoring but also talking about using
cloud composer and how you actually
update models over time how you update
this entire workflow right today for the
purposes of this approach I was the one
kind of orchestrating the data landing
in GCS cleanse with data prep you know
querying a big query and all the way to
training and deploying them
but in reality you're not gonna have a
person doing that beyond the first
couple of times and that's where
composure is really your friend and it
can help you define that entire workflow
and lets you run that on a regular basis
right again as you get new data in you
might want to retrain those models or
deploy them in a different fashion so
what is the kind of typical workflow
look like inside a Google cloud and this
is sort of a superset of what I've
covered here today but it really does go
through the steps of right we have all
the tools you need to go through from
data to ingest all the exploration
capabilities preparing it wrangling that
data may be doing some level of
pre-processing and then getting into the
machine learning components right
training hyper tuning testing and then
deploying those models either in online
predictions or in batch predictions and
under the bottom there right this whole
thing lets you that can be run by a
cloud composer all right it's that
orchestration layer all right so that's
the bulk of what I wanted to cover now
where do you go from here a couple of
things to think about as you're looking
into how do you adopt these sorts of
workflows so for training I definitely
recommend you take a look at GPUs and
maybe even TP use to boost your your
training approaches because just using
Bare CPUs you could throw a lot of
courses the problem but it's not always
the fastest way to go right GPUs and
CPUs are really really purpose-built for
linear algebra in the former case and
specifically tensorflow in the latter so
that could have a really significant
impact on your training timing I like
using batch predictions to fill in
historical data right you're not gonna
need to fill in every single request
online so if you want to fill in some of
the prior work you can do that with
batch and that puts a little bit less
strain on relying on another API to fill
data in when maybe customers are
browsing through your site looking for
recommendations for machine learning
what's even what's what's great too is
and just this week we have talked more
about using psyche at lunar and XG boost
so you don't actually have to use
tensorflow if you don't want to right
there are other ways you can get cloud
ml engine to host and serve your models
and do that prediction for you and then
the last one we talked about a little
bit as well was automating the antenna
works
with composure there's actually one
other thing I didn't get a chance to put
on here which is B qml right it's a
really powerful tool again inside of
that same interface where you can query
with standard sequel we've added some
extensions to actually do machine
learning right then and there so you can
do things like linear regression right
in line and it's really powerful again
that might not be the model use in
production but every little bit of work
you do along the way to reduce the
amount the next person has to do that
has an impact on how long it takes to
get to market so what about if you want
to learn more so I definitely urge you
to check out all of the analytics and
machine learning products that we have
inside of GCP it's an incredibly
powerful portfolio and it just continues
to grow regularly especially if you
start digging into where we're investing
around machine learning right we started
I think with the pre trained api's like
vision natural language and translation
and then we went all the way to the
other extreme and said we'll run your
tensor flow models for you at scale and
now you're seeing us invest a lot more
in just the middle right what if you
don't want to write tensorflow
but you want a custom model and that's
what Auto ml does for us so there's a
lot of work really happening there and
then I would definitely have you check
out da three or three later today a
modern data pipeline in action again it
takes this work that I'm talking about
and gives you a real-world example from
one of our customers as I mentioned
check out bigquery ml really cool I
think it's a great tool and definitely
take advantage of the free trial right
you can do things like store 10 gigs of
data for free it's at a bigquery and
your your first terabyte of processing
or query processing it's free every
month so there's a lot of wiggle room
there to start playing off these tools
and take advantage of
[Music]